Drake breaks his silence on the Pusha T
dis
kendall Jenner steps out with rumor new
beau Ben Simmons as one relative event
x2 nah she comes for him on Twitter
drama drama drama hey guys I'm Danny
direct oh this is the daily Denny and
let's get right into it
Drake and push a team a year's long feud
between the rapper's was recently
reignited when pushes he unleashed the
brutal diss track the story of added on
the song comes after Drake mentioned
pushes fiance in this past weekend
Duffey freestyle which came after push
@t called out those pesky Drake ghost
riding claims in his new album Daytona
are you followin so far because that's
just a little refresher
then there's the cover art for the story
of added on yep that's a young Drake in
blackface less than 24 hours later the
Toronto native address the photo on
Instagram he says the unedited image was
used out of context quote this picture
is from 2007 a time in my life where I
was an actor and I was working on a
project that was about young black
actors struggling to get roles being
stereotyped and typecast he added quote
the photos represented how African
Americans were once wrongfully portrayed
in entertainment well push a stop by Big
Boy's neighborhood on la's 92.3 earlier
this morning with his reaction he told
the hosts quote that doesn't change my
view at all you are silent on all black
issues Drake you don't stand for nothing
now while Drake made no direct mention
of push a tease name or his song in his
post it's easy to connect the dots here
and I'm surprised it took him so long to
do so because in the song push the tea
fires shots claiming Drizzy whose mother
is Jewish Canadian and his father as
african-american doesn't know how to
embrace his blackness he also alludes to
Drake having a secret son which was a
recent tabloid story so no babies
involved is deeper than Rev we talking
character let me keep with the facts
you are hiding a child but then boy come
home this is hardly the beginning of
their brief and who knows if this is
where it will end
doubtful but what do you guys think of
the diss track I got to say my favorite
reaction on this came on Twitter
courtesy of Andrew Teague calling a diss
track is just two grown men sitting in
separate rooms writing poems about each
other so let it out guys let it out
meanwhile kendall Jenner stepped out
with rumored new man NBA star Ben
Simmons there have been multiple reports
that the 22 year old supermodel and 21
year old Philadelphia 76ers player are
dating and on Wednesday the two were
snapped leaving the nice guy in West
Hollywood
at the same time Kendall and Ben have
reportedly been casually seeing each
other for a few weeks now you'll
remember Kendall was most recently
linked to Blake Griffin and Ben was
dating Tinashe while Tinashe his kid
brother jumped on Twitter and took aim
at Ben amid the Kendall dating reports
he tweeted never met you before in my
life
days after you break my sis heart you
cheat on her with a Jenner
Tinashe bro flooded his timeline with
retweets of fans who also defended his
sister so now I'm watching Ben Simmons
social media like a hawk but we are
switching gears now to Kendall's older
brother Brody Jenner who is set to tie
the knot any day now with his longtime
fiance Caitlyn Carter in Bali but one
person who won't be in attendance for
their I Do's the 34 year olds dad
Caitlyn Jenner source tells et the 68
year old will not attend her son's
wedding due to previously scheduled work
commitments but adds that everything is
good between them in fact according to
the source the former Olympian is
throwing a party for Brody and Kaitlynn
when they returned to Los Angeles
following their wedding and while
Caitlyn may not be there for her son's
big day she did celebrate her future
daughter-in-law in April attending her
bridal shower at the Santa Anita Park
Racetrack
in Los Angeles alongside Brody's mom
Linda Thompson Carter herself wrote
Caitlyn on Instagram
I'm so happy you were there and then a
lot to me no word if Kendall Kylie and
the rest of the family be there but I
just had to end on the light note guys
today everybody's dissing everybody
can't we all just get along I'm sending
my love to you guys for watching and
I'll see you tomorrow for new
- crying
[Music]